some people are saying Star Trek Picard
season 3 is really no better than the
first two seasons and it's just one big
massive Nostalgia Fest
do they or do they not have a point
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
move your Channel
[Music]
so I've seen a couple of news reports
going around one was on space.com one
was on Yahoo News basically saying that
Picard season 3 has just been one big
Nostalgia Fest that has really just been
one long what's in the box formula and
that really it's no different from the
first two seasons the first two seasons
that most trekkies I think is fair to
stay have problems with some like me
absolutely hated I'm really sorry fellas
I love you I do
but his pecan season three any different
well to be fair I'm going to say that
look it has been formulaic Picard season
3 has been predictable even when the
doors opened and we saw the Enterprise D
I was excited I giggled like a little
child but I was not surprised if you
actually watch our live video from
Wednesday literally the day before
episode 9 aired we basically predicted
exactly what was going to happen in this
episode
but the point is that even if something
is formulaic even if something is a
little bit predictable if done well it
can still be brilliant and the
difference between seasons one and two
of Picard and season three is that
season three has been done well
now I've had some problems with season
three
I have not really liked Beverly Chris's
character in this series I think her
keeping her son away from Picard was
cruel I think she jumps out and says
random things like that the changelings
have evolved and then the bulk have
evolved and I'm just like no evolution
is a natural process evolution is not a
technological process what happened to
the changelings was technological the
Borg that don't evolve at all they
assimilate that's the point of the Borg
so when she says things like that it
irritates me slightly
the Titan has irritated me slightly when
you refit a Starship you don't
completely rebuild the damn thing you
just update the technology so look
there's been nitpicky little things is
my point about Star Trek Picard season
three that have irritated me when I've
watched it it generally feels like they
have to make one mistaken episode but
anyway
the point though is that I've completely
ignored those errors I've completely
ignored that okay at times it's been a
bit predictable because it's been done
very very well none of the mistakes are
more than fleetingly irritating none of
the predictability is to the point of
being boring
to be honest I am a big proponent of TV
shows stripping back and being simple I
really don't like it when TV shows and
this was a problem with season one or
two Picard
that when they try to be too clever
to be honest I think simple is better
maybe that's because I'm a simple boy
but generally speaking if you have a
good story you tell it well and you keep
it simple so that it makes sense
you're gonna have a winner
when you try to do something clever for
the sake of being clever or you try and
actually have twists and turns so that
you cannot predict what's going to
happen but you cannot also make any
bloody sense of it then you're not going
to have a good show it's not going to
make sense and it's just going to be
either irritating or boring or both now
Picard season one started well
it ended badly and everything in between
was a blurry mess
Picard season two the first episode is
great the second episode other than the
entire bork bit was actually not too bad
either but it should have been like four
episodes at most it didn't have enough
story to fill up 10 episodes so in the
middle it wandered it also had massive
bits that made no sense because it was
trying to be clever and what about this
point about it being just a Nostalgia
Fest engaged
[Music]
just us fans going crazy because we got
to see the Enterprise D and we got to
see Jordy and we got to see Wharf
[Music]
foreign
there's nothing wrong with that again if
it's done well now
a lot of the time in shows we will see
that when the show is struggling for new
ideas they might bring back an old
character or they might bring back
something for us to all go oh look I
remember him I remember him
now shows do that a lot out of
desperation Picard season three might
have been done out of desperation simply
because the card season one or two are
so bloody bad
but even if it was done initially
because of that
the difference between this and shows
that have done that in the past is the
Picard season 3 was done well and that's
the point
it doesn't matter if you do these things
it doesn't matter if you have the most
original idea on the planet if you then
don't do it well
pecan season 3 simply succeeded because
it has been done with the fans in mind
it makes sense it's been exciting
there's been good writing there's been
good story there's been a few twists and
turns and yes they've thrown in the
Nostalgia this is the final generation
the last Voyages of This Crew so yeah we
wanted to see the Enterprise f
we'd have liked us in the Enterprise E
thanks Wolf but we really needed to see
the D now in the live video I said that
look this is going to happen we know
it's going to happen but it's going to
be cheesy and it was it was cheesy
but it was cheesy done well it was
Camembert cheesy I like I remember but
card season three has been a massive hit
because it has reminded us of the show
we once loved it's kind of also why
lower decks work so well for me
yes it's been a bit of a Nostalgia Fest
but it's been done just this side of
cheesy
yes it's been a bit predictable but it's
been predictable but still interesting
the beautiful thing about this show is
that it's very clearly been done by a
fan of Star Trek Four Star Trek fans and
I can only appreciate that
if it wasn't nostalgic what would the
point of the show have been this is a
good buy to This Crew if they didn't end
up on the D that would have been a crime
they needed to do this so we could see
them make their final voyage and so we
could see the Next Generation take its
final bow picasses are one or two
massively disappointing Picard season 3
has been everything every Trekkie has
ever wanted
but guys give to the comments tell me
what you think is Star Trek Picard
season 3 a Nostalgia Fest but in a good
way is it a bit predictable but not
boring is it all the things that I've
said get in the comments and tell me
exactly what you think
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go over to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack where most of
our new videos appear first and for a
small contribution each month that
really helps the channel out you get to
see it first and without the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign
[Music]